[Music]
time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week and we
begin with more on what's been a
widespread and deadly flu season
according to statistics released
yesterday from the Centers for Disease
Control 49 states are reporting
widespread influenza activity only
Hawaii was excluded with 37 related
pediatric deaths nearly 42 people per
100,000 have been hospitalized here to
discuss this and more is CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus doc
good morning good morning I'm moving to
Hawaii yeah exactly for many reasons the
flu shot is it too late should people
get it no when you get a flu shot it
takes about two weeks to build immunity
the flu get it get it get it even if it
doesn't hit the strain that's around
you're gonna get less severity to the
flu so get that flu shot if you haven't
it's older people and children are
usually the most susceptible as we know
but it's surprising to see that baby
boomers have been especially hard hit by
this David why yeah I mean this year
it's a little bit different there
certainly is a bigger incidence in the
baby boomers baby boomers are the ones
who are out there working every day and
many of them have a less vaccination
rates they're not getting the flu shots
as others are in addition there's a
particular strain this year that when
you're a child of what strains you're
exposed to you may have less immunity of
this strain it's not clear exactly why
but it's a real trend everybody needs to
get that flu shot I can't say it enough
all right we have our marching orders we
transition to our next topic health
issues on a global scale the World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland just
wrapped up experts and world leaders
discussed a variety of issues including
health and medicine dr. agus was one of
the famous attendees and can tell us
about some of the health related matters
discussed in Davos okay
so one of the sort of big topic issues
at Davos is value how does that
intersect with health well it's a big
movement now on health its value is what
you get for what you pay and whether it
be a drug whether it be a procedure if
it works you should pay more than if it
doesn't work and so developing a system
where we incentivize people for value
rather than incentivize people to do
procedures right now you get sick the
doc gets paid for doing something the
future it's going to be its base
on the outcome and I think that's an
important move the key of Davos that we
all talked about was how do we define
value one of the issues addressed in the
firm's global risk report was inequality
especially when it comes to things like
human enhancement drugs and
bioengineering to quote a section of
that write-up if the price tag is
significant and the benefits are strong
the result would be even deeper and more
entrenched inequality no question you
know we're all talking about electronic
autonomous cars but there may be burning
cars one day if we don't address this
issue we can cure diseases like
hepatitis C we're going to have drugs in
the near future that may make you
smarter stronger and if only the rich
can afford them it's going to increase
this divide that we have now we have to
figure out a way to make you know equity
in terms of dealing with healthcare with
the progress that's happening it's a
major issue today it's going to be a
more of a major issue tomorrow
that's a dystopian future right there of
course speaking of which antibiotic
antibiotic resistance is another issue
that was talked about what can you tell
us about the latest on that you know we
see in this flu season right we have
antivirals so in the first 48 hours you
take one of these a ferret severity goes
way down we're seeing some resistance
this year but there's going to be more
and as we take more and more antivirals
antibiotics drug resistance is a major
problem so we have to figure out ways to
use them appropriately and then it's set
of eyes research to make new drugs if
you have a drug that works and people
who are resistant the problem is we save
it till the end so what company wants to
make a drug we're only a few people will
use it we have to change the system
there even what were some of your
biggest takeaways from the healthcare
discussions in Davos you know in general
there's optimism there's optimism that
you know vaccines are working in Africa
there's optimism that we have new
treatments for cancer and Alzheimer's
you know one of the big discussions that
you know we sat on a stage and talked
about is health care or right and you
know I think that what came down at the
end is it is a right but it's also a
responsibility and I think defining both
of those is going to be critical as we
move forward so it was a privilege to be
there but the discussions really
hopefully push the march forward do you
think that the discussions translate
into action in the long term medium term
short term no question about it I mean
the power of Davos is who's in the room
as you have health ministers heads of
pharmaceuticals
so when you say something in the
hallways afterwards you talk about an
action happens it's an amazing place in
that regard and I'm not a bad Alpine
setting either not a bad Alpine setting
no question about it snowed a lot this
year a little cold and remote lucky you
actually David agus thanks for being
with us